fraudsters looking to steal your
identity are doing so by intercepting
your mail yeah mary jane belliesa takes
us to a neighborhood in the northwest
valley that was recently targeted and
tells you how to prevent this from
happening to you
vanessa bowie lives here in the iron
mountain community where identity
thieves tried to steal her personal
information it's a case of interception
mail fraud it started with a package
alert for a replacement credit card but
she never ordered one in bowie's case
she says id thieves took out replacement
credit cards in her name had them
delivered her address and tried to
intercept the mail by stopping the ups
driver and this isn't the first time it
happened they did speak to the ups
driver after the first time and they
said oh a person with the id and they
stuck me down the street and i'm like
okay we will never stop you down the
street
um so
that's how i kind of knew this was
happening and at the same time i think
you just have to be very diligent about
making sure because something is
innocent okay can i get a replacement
card it doesn't flag as fraud right but
you
and it's coming to your address so even
if you called you know any credit card
customer service they would say but it's
coming to your address the second time
thieves tried to intercept bowie came
prepared she already put in a claim with
the credit card company changing her
mail preferences to make sure the mail
was only delivered to her door in
bowie's door cam video you can see the
thieves follow the ups driver when i
spoke to the driver you know thanking
him for coming to the house you know
saying contacting ups telling them you
know that you
did the right thing so yeah i mean this
is definitely something that's a scheme
because it's starting from
making sure these cards are coming and
you know if you're the card holder you
may not even know that's happened
reporting here in the northwest valley
mary jane belliesa live local now
mary jane thank you bowie hopes turning
over her door cam video to police will
help catch those thieves she also
reached out to ups about the incident
and thanked them for not handing over
her mail